[Music]
hello and welcome to this episode of
Google developers live I'm Sarah Maddox
from the Google Maps developer relations
team in this video you'll learn how to
add a place autocomplete widget to a map
created with the Google Maps JavaScript
API
I'll also show you how an autocomplete
widget can be useful even without a map
to autofill an address form for example
so let's take a look at it in action
autocomplete gives your applications the
type-ahead search behavior of the search
field on a google map
start typing something into the address
box and autocomplete surprised
predictions
you can configure the autocomplete
widgets to return specific types of
places geographical places like towns
and cities or establishments like pizza
places or regions and other demographic
areas if no type is specified the widget
will return all types if you haven't
already seen our videos on getting
started with the JavaScript API now is a
really good time to watch them so let's
get started with the code if you've
created a map before you'll recognize
this as the basic JavaScript used to
create a map place autocomplete is part
of the Google Places library so our
first step is to add the Google Places
library to the JavaScript API there are
a number of libraries that provides
additional functionality for the
JavaScript API and one of them is the
Google Places library so to add a
library include a library's parameter in
the JavaScript API loader here I've
specified libraries equals places
autocomplete adds a text input element
to your page and responds with
predictions when the user types into the
textbox so we need to define an HTML
input element of type text and next we
can set some options for the
autocomplete widget so I decided to use
a default area for the search conducted
by autocomplete to define define the
area I've created a letter long bounds
object it defines a rectangle on the
earth by setting the latitude and
longitude for the southwest corner and
for the northeast corner of the
rectangle the autocomplete will bias its
search to this area but not restrict the
results to that area I've decided to
bias my search results to an area in
Sydney Australia I've also created a
variable which I've called options that
contains the bounds objects
now we hook up the HTML input element as
a variable and add some magic to push
the autocomplete widget onto the map
canvas and finally create the
autocomplete object passing it the input
element and the options object let's
take a look at the autocomplete of a
widget in action again
so one thing to note is that by default
autocomplete will automatically
determine the user's location by looking
at their IP address and will bias the
search results to that location you can
turn off this location awareness by
setting the bounds to encompass the
whole world use bounds of minus 90 minus
180 + 90 180 you can also set the bounds
- the browser's navigation navigated our
geo location object and there are other
options that you can use to customize
the autocomplete widgets the details are
all in the documentation here's a hint
you can use the geocoding API define the
latitude and longitude coordinates of
the vacation you have in mind
so here's a link to the geocoding API
documentation okay let's think outside
the map how about using autocomplete to
autofill and the dress form there's a
really nice example in the documentation
which I'm just going to show you quickly
and you can come along later and have a
look at the code in more detail here's
my address form start typing the address
where it says enter your address and
autocomplete supplies the predictions
when I select one of these predicted
places the JavaScript I have takes the
users gets placed to retrieve the
information retrieved from the Google
Places services and puts the address
into components on the form let's take a
look at the code for the address box by
scrolling down on this documentation
page
we've supplied the code after the sample
so we use get place to get the
information about the place including
the address and then we take each
element of the address and pass it and
put it into the form when the user
selects a place from the list
information about the place is returned
to the autocomplete object and your
application can grab that information
via get place and use it to populate the
fields on your form so as I said you can
come to our documentation and have a
closer look at the code and the address
form in action
what about styling you can style the
autocomplete drop-down to suit your own
branding or site design so let's see a
simple example in this example I've
colored my autocomplete box a nice
burnished yellow and styled the drop
down to match
so that's a really simple example of
styling the documentation has all the
details about the CSS classes that are
available let's have a look at the CSS
that I used so I've just styled the pec
container class and the documentation
describes all the other classes
available if JavaScript isn't your thing
or if you're working on a mobile app
have a look at the Google Places web
service - what we've been looking at is
the the javascript library i hope you've
enjoyed this video from google
developers live